here's a quick teaser number one thing
you can do is that so you want to hear
the crazy that happened to him this
will blow your mind oh God here we can
10 paranoia we go wasn't a Sim swap so
what happened is is that apple as you
know if you forget your password they
have something called I forgot which is
like you can go there and say I forgot
my password right and it says okay well
do you have another device that you can
confirm no I don't have another device
okay well what's your backup phone
number right and so you can reset that
password with the backup phone number
that you put into the system that all
makes sense right a Sim swap somebody
steals your phone number and they get
access to it and then that's how you get
compromised their Sim swaps are getting
harder to do because you know some of
the big providers have caught on and
they've tried to kind of like prevent
that from happening ask you more
questions all of that nature well
someone called in on his behalf to let
let's just say because it was you might
want to bleep that they were sponsor at
some point but they called in they faked
like it was him yeah and they didn't ask
for a Sim swap what they asked for they
said hey can you forward the phone
number just for an hour to this other
number because I need it forwarded so
normally this W so was straight social
engineering no but you straight social
engineering but listen to this normally
a forward wouldn't work because a text
message doesn't get forwarded only calls
do but you can go into apple and you can
say I have auditory problems I can't
hear can you call me with the security
code so they did a quick forward they
called it didn't go to his phone it went
to the Hacker's phone Apple read the
security code to them via audio they put
it in compromise reset it changed his
phone number compromise download all of
his data and then tried to blackmail him
to get his data back oh my God okay so
in terms of teasers for yes teaser
number one thing to do is that you want
a cell phone provider where there is not
a phone number to call and it's really
truly securely locked down your best
provider for that in the United States
is Google F and what you do is you don't
set it up with your Google account you
create a brand new Gmail account that no
one knows timtim secure 8537 gmail.com
you just docks me so hard exactly and
then you you two- Factor the off the
crap out of that turn on Google's
Advanced protection there then you sign
up for Google fly account which is a
brand new phone number then you tell
Apple that is your backup phone number
because Apple can still service your
main number but only use that backup
number to reset passwords so there's no
possible way anyone would know that
backup number and so it's it's a whole
thing there's more steps to it than that
you know you get Hardware Keys involved
like Google's Titan key which is the the
most like hardcore of the USBC you know
Keys Hardware Keys uses one of their
Titan chips which is legit it's a whole
thing but it's scary yeah
terrifying